kommen damit zu einem komplett anderen
thema es geht um den bundeswehreinsatz
im irak vor zwei wochen hatte der
bundestag darüber auch schon diskutiert
das mandat soll bis zum 31
oktober verlängert werden so der wunsch
der bundesregierung 500 deutsche
soldatinnen und soldaten
wir sollen dafür eingesetzt werden
können
der bundestag hatte ende oktober 2020
eine mandatsverlängerung bis januar 2022
beschlossen also bis ende januar das
heißt das mandat läuft jetzt aus damals
hatten sich die grünen noch gegen diesen
einsatz
ein
ausgesprochen und hier wurde eben eva
högl auch begrüßt die liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen das bundes wehrbeauftragte
des bundestags die heute hier auch zu
und diese würden wir hoffen sie auch eva
högl ist jetzt hier auch in bildern neu
50 zusagen als anwältin auch bezeichnet
wird der deutschen soldatinnen und
soldaten erste rednerin ist jetzt sara
nanni verteidigungspolitische sprecherin
der grünen fraktion
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
bundeswehr ist eine parlamentsarmee
wir können im bundestag über ihren
einsatz entscheiden das ist im
internationalen vergleich nicht
selbstverständlich aus diesem recht
ergibt sich aber auch eine pflicht
nämlich die pflicht genau hinzuschauen
auf das land in dem wir engagiert sind
und auf die menschen und auf die
soldaten die dort ihren dienst leisten
der irak leidet nach wie vor unter dem
terror des sogenannten islamischen
staates die bedrohung ist zwar nicht
mehr zu vergleichen mit der wie sie sich
vor ein paar jahren dargestellt hat als
ein territorium teile von syrien und
teile von irak de facto von einer terror
organisation regiert wurden aber die
herausforderung bleiben trotzdem riesig
und deshalb ist das ziel des anders los
stabilität und sicherheit zu fördern
richtig
es gibt zwei änderungen im mandat die es
wesentlich verbessern und auf ein
solideres fundament stellen erstmals
fokussiert sich das mandat nun auf den
irak syrien ist als mandatsgebiet haus
gelaufen und zweitens beschließen wir
mit dem mandat dass wir es um fassung
evaluieren werden und das ist neu
wir haben uns das als ampel für alle
mandate vorgenommen das irak mandat ist
das erste bei dem dieses vorhaben zur
anwendung kommen wird das ist gut
richtig und wichtig und ich freue mich
sehr darauf diese prozess der evaluation
auch hier im parlament zu begleiten
der deutsche einsatz in iraks findet in
zwei unterschiedlichen kontexten stadt
in der nato mission in iraq und in der
so genannten erst koalition es ist kein
geheimnis dass wir als grüne mit der
koalition der willigen die die anti erst
koalition nach wie vor da stellt ein
grundsätzliches problem hatten an der
politischen bewertung dass solche
einsätze besser im rahmen von sich und
systemsicherheit
system kollektiver sicherheit standbein
soll hat sich nichts geändert und ich
bin sehr froh dass sich die
ampelkoalition diese auffassung durch
den koalitionsvertrag auch angeschlossen
hat
hier den rahmen eines multinationalen
einsatz ändert man nicht in sechs wochen
regierungszeit und das was die menschen
in iran brauchen ist verlässlichkeit
auch unsere es sind nach wie vor
herausfordernde zeiten die wahlen sind
technisch und von den abläufen her
gelungen politisch ist die
regierungsbildung bildung allerdings
immer noch mehr als schwierig die
sicherheitskräfte sind heute besser
aufgestellt und noch vereinigung als
noch vor einiger zeit trotzdem können
anschläge des nicht vollständig
verhindert werden und sie mehren sich
sogar auch gegen die sicherheitskräfte
selbst
die leichten verbesserung der
beziehungen zwischen der
zentralregierung und der regierung im
nordirak sind in ihrer politischen
bedeutung nicht zu unterschätzen
trotzdem bleibt es dabei sie sind
schwierig und es gibt akteure die ethno
politisieren den konflikt weiter und
sind nicht auf kooperation und
versöhnung aus hier weiter an der seite
der menschen in irak zu stehen ist mehr
als ein wichtiges zeichen auch für die
region
der einsatz leistet einen beitrag zur
stabilisierung und ermöglicht das
humanitäre hilfe
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und die
zivile arbeit die arbeit leisten kann
dies leisten muss damit es
perspektivisch aufwärts geht die
deutschen soldatinnen befinden sich in
dierath in einem gefährlichen
sicherheitsumfeld ihr beitrag ist auch
was die entbehrung im privaten rangeht
nicht zu unterschätzen ihnen gilt unser
ausdrücklicher dank
leider konnte ich vor der verlängerung
des mandats die truppe vor ort noch
nicht besuchen sobald das möglich ist
möchte ich das tun die ministerin und
auch unsere ausschussvorsitzende waren
schon da und ich finde das ist nicht nur
ein wichtiges zeichen der anerkennung
sondern auch essenziell für das was
jetzt auf uns zukommt
denn unser job zum irak endet nicht mit
dem beschluss dieses mandats unser job
als parlament wird es sein nicht erst
wieder dann hinzuschauen wenn es um die
verlängerung geht sondern schon die
ganze zeit dazwischen das haben die
menschen in irak das hat unsere
soldatinnen verdient dazu lade ich sie
herzlich ein und bitte heute um ihre
zustimmung zu diesem mann darf
dankeschön
vielen dank frau kollegin anni
es folgt nun
für die cdu/csu-fraktion der kollege
doch bern aber trocken
norbert röttgen in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode den ausschuss den
auswärtigen ausschuss geleitet ist jetzt
mehr turin und kollegen die cdu csu
fraktion stimmt dem antrag der
bundesregierung den irak einsatz der
bundeswehr v zu setzen zu der islamische
staat hat erfreulicherweise keine
gewichtskontrolle mehr im irak aber er
ist immer noch eine gefährdung des
friedens und der stabilität im irak
selber ist es sieht es besser aus als
lange zuvor aber der irak ist weiterhin
fragil er braucht weiter internationale
stabilisierungs unterstützung
dass man das was wir heute beschließen
ist praktisch die fortsetzung des
bisherigen einsatzes des bisherigen
mandate es gibt eine kleine textliche
anpassung an die realität des einsatzes
nämlich die beschränkung des
einsatzgebietes auf den irak das war die
realität des einsatzes jetzt ist es auch
die textliche fassung des mandates das
aber nicht wesentlich weise schon immer
die realität war die cdu csu fraktion
hat als regierungsfraktionen die sind
dem antrag der bundesregierung
zugestimmt und wir stimmen jetzt als
oppositionsfraktion dem antrag der
bundesregierung zu wir stimmen zu aus
außenpolitischer verantwortung unserer
außenpolitische verantwortung ist
unabhängig davon welche parlamentarische
rolle die cdu csu fraktion war
es gibt es gibt zwei veränderungen auf
die ich eingehen möchte eine hier bei
uns im haus und eine außenpolitische
veränderung die im haus besteht darin
dass die fraktion der grünen jetzt als
regierungsfraktion
dieses mandat als regierungs teil der
regierung einbringen und als
regierungsfraktion auch zustimmen als
die oppositionsfraktion waren haben sie
immer gegen diesen antrag gegen den
antrag der bundesregierung gestimmt und
zwar aus verfassungsrechtlichen
völkerrechtlichen gründen ich erwähne
das gar nicht mit irgendeiner form der
helme der anpassung dass dafür
rechtliche auffassung an die an die an
die tatsächlichen der rechtlichen
auffassung an die parlamentarische rolle
das tue ich nicht sondern ich erwähne es
um positiv und so und wenn sie den
kurswechsel vornehmen das will ich dann
doch sagen weil wir so reagiert dann
sollten sie auch zu ihm stehen sie
sollten an transparenz an sie sollten
sagen wir haben unsere meinung geändert
das ist legitim in der politik aber sie
sollten sich nicht beschweren dass wenn
ein meinungswechsel vorgenommen wird
durch sie darauf auch sich andere
fraktionen erlauben darauf hinzuweisen
dass sie jetzt eine neue meinte dass man
nicht muss erlaubt sein
ich wollte es ausschließlich positiv
darstellen und bleibe auch bei meiner
positiven darstellung weil die
konsequenz ihres kurswechsels jetzt
darin besteht dass der
verfassungsrechtliche und
völkerrechtliche konsens über diesen
bundeswehreinsatz und damit auch
vergleichbare
bundeswehreinsätze breiter geworden ist
wir haben jetzt einen konsens dieser
fraktionen mit ausnahme der
linksfraktion der afg fraktion über die
verfassungsrechtliche und
völkerrechtliche bewertung das bewerte
ich positiv weil dieser außenpolitischen
konsens eine stärke unseres landes ist
das war der punkt warum ich sie wählen
kann
das ist der grund warum ich auch hier
ausdrücklich für das protokoll den
antragstext den wir jetzt fraktionen
vier fraktionen zustimmen zitiere damit
klar ist was unsere
verfassungsrechtlichen völkerrechtliche
auffassung nun hier gemeinsam ist ich
zitiere aus dem antrag ziffer 2 letzter
absatz verfassungsrechtliche grundlage
für den einsatz ist artikel 24 absatz 2
des grundgesetzes
der einsatz erfolgt hinsichtlich seiner
zielrichtung der unterbindung eines
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff vom bs
sowie der herstellung des weltfriedens
und der internationalen sicherheit im
rahmen und nach den regeln eines systems
kollektiver sicherheit den vereinten
nationen das ist jetzt unsere gemeinsame
verfassungsrechtliche und
völkerrechtliche auffassung ich begrüße
sehr dass wir diese zustimmung im haus
unter den demokratischen fraktionen
erzielt haben ich möchte einen zweiten
punkt erwähnen der veränderung der uns
arbeit und aufgabe aufgibt und das ist
eine außenpolitische veränderung die
wesentliche außenpolitische veränderung
besteht darin dass die vereinigten
staaten von amerika die region des nahen
mittleren ostens im allgemeinen und den
irak im besonderen nicht mehr als ihre
außenpolitische priorität betrachten ist
ein wesentlicher kurskorrektur wir sind
in afghanistan wir sehen uns jetzt auch
im irak es wird es gibt keinen
amerikanischen kampfeinsatzes gedopt ein
kampfeinsatz der nato mehr das ist
rückzug der usa aus der region es ist
die fokussierung der usa die neue
bestimmung ihrer prioritäten und vor
allen dingen auf schienen
die frage ist was bedeutet das für
deutschland was bedeutet das für europa
wir haben vor allen dingen in der
sogenannten flüchtlingskrise gelernt
dass wir die sicherheit in deutschland
die sicherheit in europa nicht von der
sicherheitslage im nahen und mittleren
osten trennen können wir deutsche
deutschland europa hat nicht das
privileg entscheiden zu können dass uns
diese nachbarregion nicht interessiert
und nicht mehr unsere priorität ist und
darum bedeutet der rückzug der usa für
uns die frage die wir beantworten müssen
was ist die strategie deutschlands
außenpolitische strategie deutschlands
und europas für diese nachbarregion die
für unsere sicherheit essentiell und
existenziell ist die frage harte
beantworten jeder bundeswehreinsatz ist
nur so gut wie das außenpolitisch
konzept in das er eingebettet ist gut
ist und diese strategische antwort auf
die einbettung dieses einsatzes fehlt
sie muss geliefert werden der antrag ist
befristet zum ende oktober dann werden
wir neu bestimmen und bis dahin ist auch
mit dem antrag geht es für neun monate
da kommen sie terrorismus ist die zeit
gekauft diese strategische frage was ist
das politische konzept des bundeswehr
einsatzes für den irak und die region zu
beantworten wir müssen diese antwort
liefern in unserem eigenen
sicherheitsinteresse in acht monaten
sehen wir uns wieder und dann warten wir
auf die antwort der regierung wir werden
auch unsere antworten geben und wir
würden uns freuen wenn wir zu einer
staaten übereinstimmung in dieser frage
kommen für sein
[Applaus]
land eine politische strategie
jetzt gibt es eine kurzintervention von
jürgen trittin den grünen
durchaus zur kenntnis genommen
dass sie hier ohne häme argumentieren
wollten
aber da wir ja über protokoll und
ähnliches sprechen muss ich sie auf zwei
dinge hinweisen
wir haben dieses mandat weil es
eingeschlossen hat
operationen
der bundeswehr über einen souveränen
staat
für völkerrechtswidrig gehalten
und genau dieses haben wir substanziell
aus diesen rausgestrichen das ist keine
textliche änderung sondern das
festhalten an unserer
völkerrechtlichen position
die kommen zu einem zweiten punkt wir
haben auch verfassungsrechtliche
einwände was das agieren außerhalb eines
bündnisses kollektiver sicherheit angeht
und dieses problem haben wir abzuwägen
dagegen
dass wir
keine plötzliche veränderung in einem
einsatz wollten wo wir die ausbildung
von soldatinnen und soldaten im nordirak
und auch im zentraliran und wir haben
andere parteien hier im hause dafür
kritisiert dass es nicht unter dem dach
der nato geschehen ist nicht aufgegeben
sondern wir haben dies ausdrücklich
davor fath von nanni vorhin hingewiesen
zum gegenstand der evaluierung gemacht
aber in der abwägung ob wir aus diesem
grunde nicht neun monate warten können
oder rausgehen haben wir uns dafür
entschieden das anliegen was wir immer
für richtig gefunden haben auch weiter
zu machen und deswegen gebe ich hiermit
offiziell zur protokoll wir haben auch
unsere verfassungsrechtliche position
nicht geändert
der außenpolitische sprecher der grünen
fraktion war das mit einer
kurzintervention jetzt kann eine
erwiderung von
norbert röttgen fall
frau präsidentin kolleginnen kollegen
ein kollege trittin ich bedauere ihre
aus ihrer wortmeldung
außerordentlich weil weil mir sehr daran
gelegen war die feststellung zu treffen
dass wir jetzt über diesen einsatz und
den typus dieses einsatzes in diesem
haus einen konsens haben was die
verfassungsrechtlichen und
völkerrechtlichen grundlagen anbelangt
ich habe ja eben die passage zitiert die
exakt dieselbe passage ist wie in der
wie die bundesregierung in den früheren
mandaten formuliert hat
und die haben sie früher abgelehnt ich
könnte auch sogar ausdrücklich vorlesen
was sie wie sie dort formuliert haben
und jetzt stimmen sie dieser passage zu
sie können herr kollege trittin nicht
gleichzeitig ausdrücklich expressis
verbis in einem antrag der
bundesregierung diesen einsatz für
verfassungs rechtskonform und
völkerrechtskonform erklären und
gleichzeitig hier ihre bedenken was die
contrexx konformität anbelangt zu
protokoll geben entweder oder entweder
ist es rechtmäßig oder es ist nicht
rechtens
und dieser zweifel stört mich weil die
argumente die sie vortragen
scheinargumente sind sie sagen wir haben
ja jetzt eine evaluierungs clausen da
drin das heißt wir werden evaluieren wir
was es mit diesem auf mit diesem einsatz
auf sich hat wenn sie diesen einsatz für
völkerrechtswidrig halten dann wird er
auch nicht rechtmäßig dadurch dass sie
ein völker einen völkerrechtswidrigen
einsatz evaluieren evaluieren macht
nicht rechtmäßig wenn es
völkerrechtswidrig ist es
völkerrechtswidrig dann wird er auch der
evaluierung nicht rechtmäßig
das ist eindeutig und
die beschränkung auf syrien ist nicht
relevant für die ablehnung gewesen die
sie vorgetragen haben ich zitiere jetzt
mal aus einer stadt kollege aber runden
sich jetzt bitte ohne ist mit diesem
zitat ab
aus den grünen den spitzen der grünen
die ablehnung wurde wurde begründet wie
folgt der mangelnde einsatz für ein
un-mandat spiegelt der mangelnde einsatz
für eine ändern da das gibt es immer
noch nicht spiegelt eine geringschätzung
von uno und völkerrecht wieder der wir
als grüne auf keinen fall entgegen
kommen dürfen deutschland kann die un
die uno international stärken indem es
gegenüber den bündnispartnern deutlich
macht dass ohne mandat nichts geht es
immer noch die lage heute
zusammenfassend position der grünen an
erfordert rechtswidriges vorgehen ist
immer auch verfassungswidrig da es hier
eine klare bindung an das grundgesetz
gibt das haben sie verändert ich finde
es positiv dass sie mit der heutigen
beschlussfassung ihren kurs wechseln wir
begrüßen das außerordentlich und sie
sollten dazu stehen was sie beschließen
[Applaus]
so das haben wir jetzt
ausgetragen und jetzt erhält das wort
für die spd-fraktion tatsächlich ist es
seine erste rede im deutschen bundestag
michael müller
vielen dank frau präsidentin meine damen
und herren dieser antrag diese dieser
tagesordnungspunkt ist alles andere als
politische routine und ich verstehe alle
mitglieder des parlaments die immer
wieder kritisch hinterfragen auf welcher
grundlage können wir unsere bundeswehr
in auslandseinsätze schicken und auch
ich teile die position dass ein
militärisches engagement unseres landes
nie eine selbstverständlichkeit sein
darf sondern immer im einzelfall geprüft
und im einzelfall entschieden werden
muss meine damen und herren es gibt auch
dass es unstrittig auch durch unsere
antwort durch unser engagement erfolge
gegen den es ja er konnte zurückgedrängt
werden er hat nicht mehr die kraft der
letzten jahre aber er ist eben immer
noch nicht noch längst nicht besiegt
immer wieder erneute terror anschläge
machen das deutlich insbesondere
anschläge unter denen auch die
zivilbevölkerung leidet und ich glaube
meine damen und herren ein terror der
auch schnell wieder bei uns eine rolle
spielen kann dieses morden zu beenden
das darf man nicht auf halber strecke
aufgeben sondern wir sollten uns auch
deswegen weiter engagieren auch um die
irakischen kräfte vor ort weiter zu
befähigen aus eigener kraft in den
auseinandersetzung mit dem er es zu
bestehen ausbildung zb in die
sicherheitsstrukturen sind wichtig und
müssen fortgesetzt werden
insbesondere auch an den stellen wo es
durch die korona zeit nicht so umgesetzt
werden konnte wie ursprünglich geplant
ein zweiter wesentlicher punkt der die
zustimmung hier heute allen ermöglichen
sollte ist doch der einsatz der
humanitären hilfe über drei milliarden
euro wurden inzwischen eingesetzt für
wasserversorgung gesundheitsversorgung
für bildungsangebote für dinge also für
infrastruktur um die situation vor ort
zu stabilisieren um der bevölkerung
konkret zu helfen und das wiederum ist
ein fundament auch in zukunft für
staatliche souveränität und
eigenverantwortung des irak diese
humanitäre hilfe ein wesentlicher ansatz
unseres engagement
meine damen und herren ein dritter punkt
den ich erwähnte der wichtig ist für
unsere zustimmung ist dass dieser
einsatz gewünscht ist ja wir haben die
un wir haben die resolution des
sicherheitsrates aber wir haben vor
allen dingen den wunsch auch der
irakischen regierung die beiden
ministerinnen außenministerin und
verteidigungsministerin haben das
eindrucksvoll
vor 14 tagen hier bestätigt dass sie auf
ramprecht bei ihrem besuch vor ort genau
damit konfrontiert worden ist dass die
irakische regierung erwartet dass sich
die bundesrepublik weiter engagiert
genauso im übrigen wie auch unsere
bündnispartner vor ort wir befinden uns
in dem kampf gegen den terror in einer
internationalen solidarität in einem
internationalen bündnis vor ort und die
kompetenzen der bundeswehr sind
gewünscht und sind gefordert ob es die
luftraumüberwachung ist die
luftbetankung ist und auch deswegen
meine damen und herren glaube ich es
dringend geboten dass wir uns weiter
engagieren und ein weiteres halte ich
persönlich auch für einen entscheidenden
punkt das ist das thema der evaluierung
wir werden uns diese koalition hat sich
das vorgenommen viel intensiver mit der
frage auseinandersetzen auf welcher
grundlage
engagieren wir uns militärisch wo jetzt
wo in zukunft und vor allen dingen wie
sind diese einsätze gestaltet wir
beginnen auch mit einem
untersuchungsausschuss zum thema
afghanistan wird es das geben mit einer
enquete kommission die das umfassend
auch beleuchtet dieses engagement aber
vor allen dingen dieses mandat irak ist
das erste wonach vielen ankündigungen
der letzten jahre es nun endlich zu dem
punkt kommt wo genau hingeguckt wird ob
das was wir wollen nämlich dieser
vernetzte ansatz
militärisch und humanitär zu helfen ob
das den gewünschten erfolg hat und mit
welchen folgen vor ort wie er dort auch
tätig sind meine damen und herren das
ist nicht alles einfach ein weiter so
sondern der verlängerungs zeitraum um
neun monate auch die veränderung des
einsatzgebietes ohne syrien eben und vor
allen dingen auch diese intensive
evaluierung das inhaltliche hinterfragen
unseres ansatzes ist eine völlig neue
qualität das ist nicht scheinheilig und
das wird nicht gemacht um den grünen
über eine zustimmung hier zu helfen
sondern herr kollege röttgen das wird
gemacht weil es schlichtweg
verantwortungsbewusst es immer wieder
kritisch zu hinterfragen
auf welcher grundlage anfangen
meine damen und herren es
zeichnet sich her zum glück wie ich
finde mich freut das sehr hier im haus
ist auf zwei fraktionen doch eine breite
mehrheit für die zustimmung zum antrag
der bundesregierung und ich glaube dass
das ein wichtiges signal dieses
parlament das ist ein wichtiges signal
in richtung unserer bündnispartner ein
richtiger ein wichtiges signal
sicherlich auch für den irak und die
verantwortlichen vor ort selbst vor
allen dingen meine damen und herren aber
auch für unsere bevölkerung und für die
soldatinnen und soldaten
das sind männer und frauen unserer
bundeswehr eine parlamentsarmee
die vor ort hervorragende arbeit leistet
und die wie ich finde ihn gerade auch
als parlamentsarmee wenn wir sie in so
einen einsatz schicken eine breite
unterstützung dieses hauses verdient die
spd fraktion wird diesem antrag der
bundesregierung zustimmen vielen dank
bisher war dass wir hier angekündigt mit
seiner ersten rede im bundestag
natürlich hat er schon viele reden
gehalten er war bis vor kurzem
regierender bürgermeister
von berlin und ist jetzt aber im
bundestag
spricht jetzt für die ard fraktion erst
mitglied des verteidigungsausschusses
frau präsidentin der ja die kolleginnen
und kollegen ganz folien im mandatstext
ist ein offensichtlicher
formelkompromiss der links gelben
koalition zeugt von ignoranz ideologie
und selbstbetrug den ignoriert die
machtverhältnisse in syrien ignoriert
dass eigentlich die agieren des nato
partners türkei operiert den einfluss
des iran und der iranischen milizen in
der region und der ignoriert die
irakische zerrissenheit ist alles in
folge der islamisch konflikte und
westliche interventionen die haben die
koalitionäre hingegen sind sich immer
wieder einmal einig für das gute
einzutreten und der vernetzte ansatz
wird wieder als problemlösung
angepriesen die logi sierte politik wird
nun schon seit jahren von 600 koalition
verfolgt allerdings immer ohne erfolg
so versteigt sich nun die unionsfraktion
trotz des scheiterns in afghanistan zu
der behauptung deutschland wird am
euphrat und tigris verteidigt und stimmt
die mandat kritiklos zu
das grundübel das vorliegende mandats
ist jedoch nicht aus der welt zur grünen
gewissensberuhigung muss es eben
verschleiert werden syrien ist wirklich
mehr einsatzgebiet des mandats counter
de existiert aber weiterhin ein
deutlicher selbstbetrug im angesichts
der zuvor vertretenen positionen als
hier im oktober 2020 auch erst der heute
noch gültige mandat zur verlängerung
anstand sprach der grüne abgeordnete
tobias lindner heute staatsminister im
auswärtigen amt davon dass das mandat
nicht nur völkerrechtswidrig sei sondern
auch ein untaugliches mittel wären aber
betankt das deutsche tankflugzeug nicht
weiterhin französische und amerikanische
kampfflugzeuge die anschließend
völkerrechtswidrige einsatz für die
ohren fliegen
diese fragen was sie sich bei den grünen
beantworten denn sie von den grünen die
bis zur wahl so vehement gegen den krieg
einer koalition der willigen mit
deutscher beteiligung waren sie
unterstützen und genau das was sie zuvor
zutiefst abgelehnt haben den einsatz
gegen counter desch und ein beispiel der
grünen schizophrenie haben ja in dem der
frage gerade eben bekommen bei den
innovationen von kollegen trittin
wir sind aber auch nicht so vergesslich
wie die fdp die nato trainingsmission im
irak unterdessen ihr es in syrien sind
nach wie vor zwei aufträge in einem
mandat
zwei aufträge die sowohl geografisch wie
auch methodisch voneinander
unterschiedliche ziele verfolgen
da gehört das mandat erteilt das wussten
sie von der fdp in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode noch sehr gut und sie
haben es seit 2010 bei jeder
mandatsverlängerung gefordert
nun sind sie in der regierung wird
hätten die bundestag doch über beide
aufträge getrennt abstimmen lassen
können aber das wäre wohl nicht so im
sinne der grünen gewesen
hier opfern sie von der fdp bereitwillig
die überzeugung für den links gelten
koalitionsfrieden
meine damen und herren das mandat muss
geteilt werden geteilt damit über luft
getankt und luftraumüberwachung so wie
wir die trainingsmission in mir sagt
getrennt abstimmen können es
bedauerlicherweise nicht geschehen daher
legen wir das mandat ab vielen dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank
nächster redner in dieser debatte wird
ulrich lechte sein der sitzt für die fdp
und ausschuss für auswärtige politik und
sich auch so zu bundeswehreinsätzen
[Applaus]
offensichtlich größer geworden sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das gerade die
afg von schizophrenie im hause spricht
also sorry to say aber ihr seid hier
immer der kasperle verein der
unterschiedlichsten sachen vorträgt und
uns hier wirklich
mehr als amüsierte manchen bereichen und
gerade der kollege orten dass sie wieder
reden hier vortragen die vermutlich gar
nicht ihre meinung entsprechen tut mir
leid das ist das ist die schizophrenie
die eigentliche aber bitte der anlass zu
sagen heute morgen in diesem einsatz
planen die abscheulichen verbrechen der
terrororganisation islamischer staat im
irak und syrien seit 2014 und die erst
terroristen haben damals ganze
landstriche erobert und dort die
bevölkerung tyrannisiert besonders die
g7 wurden opfer von folter
vergewaltigung versklavung und
völkermord das konnten wir erfolgreich
beenden angesichts dieser gräueltaten
möchte ich vor allem auch mal den
juristinnen und juristen meinen dank
aussprechen
die sich um die aufarbeitung dieser
verbrechen bemühen in den letzten jahres
kam es am oberlandesgericht frankfurt zu
einer verurteilung im weltweit ersten
strafprozess wegen völkermordes an den
juden und dieser prozess nach dem
weltrechtsprinzip
es ein wichtiges signal das die
strafverfolgung von völkermord und
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
nicht an landesgrenzen halt macht es war
keine leichte
aufgabe
diese gräueltaten aus der ferne von
deutschland aus aufzuklären dafür gilt
unser dank zu dem haus vermutlich von
den meisten an unsere juristinnen und
juristen
die aufarbeitung ist also bereits im
gang gs ist noch nicht vollständig
besiegt er wurde zurückgedrängt und
beherrscht keine gebiete mehr aber es
gibt ihn noch in der verfügt weiterhin
terroranschläge im irak deshalb bietet
die irakische regierung und weiterhin um
unterstützung und dieser bitte möchten
wir auch mit diesem mandat erneut
nachkommen meine damen und herren
darüber sind wir uns in diesem hause
weit gehen nicht eigentlich und beides
wie haben wir bereits diskutiert und es
gab auch gute gründe die ausgestaltung
vorheriger irak mandate der rechts roten
koalition zu kritisieren ich finde es
daher unangebracht wenn einige in
unserem haus die grünen dafür
kritisieren dass sie bei früheren irak
mandaten mit nein gestimmt haben aber
jetzt beim geänderten mandat mit ja
stimmen das hat nämlich nichts mit
wankelmütigkeit zu tun sondern liegt
schlicht und ergreifend an der
berücksichtigung von bedingungen die nun
bei der ausgestaltung des mandats
eingebaut wurden
daher möchte ich gerne daran erinnern
dass wir auch von der fdp noch im jahr
2009 10 gegen das damalige ragt mandat
der rechts roten koalition gestimmt
hatten unser nein hatten wir damals mit
klaren bedingungen geknüpft bei deren
erfüllung wird zustimmen können ganz
besonders wichtig war uns die
multilaterale einbindung unseres
engagements im irak statt der reinen
bilateralen auf ausbildungsmission
damals ist unser engagement zur
unterstützung des irakischen
sicherheitssektors inzwischen
eingebettet in die nato mission im irak
dieses gemeinsame multilaterale vorgehen
ist uns als fdp besonders wichtig daher
freut es auch mich ganz besonders dass
wir die stärkung des multilateralismus
es als ersten punkt des außenpolitik
kapitals kapitels im koalitionsvertrag
verankert haben so zeigen wir auch
gemeinsam als ampel wie wichtig uns der
multilateralismus
ist meine damen und herren wir bitten
sie ein bisschen stimmung zu diesen nun
geänderten mandat damit wir auch
weiterhin den irak in seinem kampf gegen
die es terroristen unterstützen können
ganz besonders möchte ich unseren
soldatinnen und soldaten würdigen die
mit vollem einsatz und ihrer expertise
unsere beschlüsse umsetzen und dem
irakischen volk helfend zur seite stehen
und ein weiterer punkt ganz zum schluss
dem wir als fdp gefordert hatten ist ja
die evaluation der bundeswehreinsätze da
wurde hier oft genug darüber gesprochen
das erste mandat was der bundestag
beschließt hat diese evaluation jetzt in
seinem antragstext drin und dafür danke
ich den partnern in unserer
ampelkoalition dass wir es schaffen das
auf den weg zu bringen was über jahre
nicht möglich gewesen ist vielen
herzlichen dank
ulrich schlechte war das für die
fdp-fraktion hat hier zum schluss noch
mal die evaluierungs klausel
angesprochen die jetzt hier im antrag
mit eingefügt wurde da geht es
insbesondere um die lage vor ort der
irakische bedarf und die rechtlichen
rahmenbedingungen die in den blick
genommen werden um zu schauen inwieweit
dieses mandat fortentwickelt wird
jacqueline das spricht jetzt für die
linksfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren erst gestern haben wir
über das 20 jährige bestehen des
foltergefängnisses guantanamo diskutiert
und der notwendigkeit seiner schließung
guantanamos ist das symbol für
menschenrechtsverletzungen aber leider
auch der doppelten standards teilen der
westlichen staaten und dazu war
insbesondere in den letzten wochen
auffällig das schweigen der
bundesregierung und das kritisieren wir
als linke
guantanamo steht aber auch für den
sogenannten krieg gegen den terror der
seitens der usa nach nein begonnen wurde
und schauen wir in den irak und das dort
von der usa implementierte system das
sehr anfällig ist für korruption aber
auch weiter das land ins verderben
stürzt der irak leidet immer noch an den
13-jährigen sanktionen der usa die eine
halbe million kinder das leben gekostet
haben in teilen des landes gibt es eine
arbeitslosenquote von 50 prozent die
infrastruktur ist kaputt wasser ist
mangelware
strom gibt es nur wenige stunden am tag
meine damen und herren ein
erfolgskonzept und projekt sieht anders
aus
und ja die es existiert noch und er geht
regelmäßig anschläge damit begründen sie
auch unter anderem die fortführung des
einsatzes aber haben sie in all den
jahren eigentlich nichts dazugelernt der
es konnte erst unter der us-besatzung
überhaupt entstehen und so mächtig
werden er ernährt sich aus den groll der
bevölkerung gegen die fremden besatzer
und unter der us besetzung wurden
menschen verschleppt gefoltert
misshandelt und auch gemordet und das
kritisieren wir als linke massiv
und sie von den grünen sprechen von
einer werte basierten außenpolitik es
gab ja auch hier die diskussion auch zu
dem völkerrecht weil sie eben dem jetzt
zustimmen möchten weil der syrische
luftraum dort raus genommen wurde sie
ignorieren vollkommen eben dass es keine
keine us mandatierung rouen mandatierung
dafür gibt aber vor allem generieren sie
dass das parlament im irak schon vor
zwei jahren einstimmig beschlossen hat
dass alle fremden soldaten das land
verlassen die linke lehnt dieses mandat
weiter ab
soweit dann kommt der obfrau der
linksfraktion im verteidigungsausschuss
wir haben noch zwei redner in dieser
debatte zum bundeswehr einsatz
um das wieder erstatten dass es zu
verhindern
jetzt spricht thomas endl für die
unionsfraktion mitglied im auswärtigen
ausschuss frau präsidentin vielen dank
liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
seit sieben jahren unterstützen unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten die irakischen
streitkräfte und die internationale
gemeinschaft im kampf gegen den
islamischen staat es ist die einzig
richtige entscheidung dass dieses mandat
jetzt fortgeführt wird und wir als cdu
csu werden dem zustimmen aus der pflicht
heraus den islamischen den
islamistischen terror weiter bekämpfen
zu müssen
in partnerschaft mit der irakischen
regierung und der kurdischen
regionalregierung und schließlich aus
respekt unseren soldatinnen und soldaten
gegenüber die rückhalt für die
fortführung dieses wichtigen einsatzes
brauchen meine damen und herren
dieses mandat zustimmen heißt aber nicht
dass alles gut ist was die regierung uns
herr vorgelegt hat die ampel regierung
will dieses mandat nur für neun monate
verlängern ich finde das ist ein
schwieriges signal an unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten unsere partner frau
kollegin anni sie sprachen von
verlässlichkeit ich finde nicht dass
dies ein signal der verlässlichkeit ist
sondern ein signal der verunsicherung
völlig unnötig der verunsicherung der
irakischen regierung unserer partner und
den soldatinnen und soldaten gingen
und wenn es um signale geht meine damen
und herren dann finde ich jetzt schon
problematisch dass hier in einer region
bei der die lage alles andere als gut
ist unser engagement immer weiter
einschränken wir haben diese leute
gesehen wie der es zu schlagen kann und
wir sehen auch im hintergrund dass sich
die usa aus dem nahen osten mehr und
mehr zurückziehen wir in deutschland
sind doch unmittelbar von der
sicherheitslage in der region betroffen
und das muss auch berücksichtigung in
unserem engagement finden weiter hin und
her und wenn es um signale geht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
dann hätte ich mir eigentlich gewünscht
wenn die neue regierung das erste mal
soldatinnen und soldaten in den
auslandseinsatz geschickt dass hier der
bundeskanzler sitzt aber es ist niemals
die verteidigungsministerien da es hält
mich mal die verteidigungsministerien
nötig hier zu sein und das ist ein ganz
ganz schwieriges signal liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
meine damen und herren ich
möchte den soldatinnen und soldaten fern
der heimat für diesen einsatz sehr sehr
herzlich danken wir als cdu csu stehen
weiterhin hinter ihnen
liegt kam wir hoffen dass die afl
parteien ihrer internationalen
verantwortung ebenfalls gerecht werden
und auch geschlossen für diesen einsatz
im irak stellen wir sind gespannt
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr kollege
und als letzter redner in dieser debatte
erhält für die spd-fraktion der kollege
dr christian klingt das wort und es ist
seine erste rede im deutschen bundestag
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren ich empfinde es als eine ehre
heute zu ihnen sprechen zu dürfen
diejenigen die die entscheidung treffen
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten in einen
auslandseinsatz zu schicken tragen eine
große verantwortung
ich habe diese verantwortung in den
letzten tagen deutlich gespürt und ich
habe bei den vorgesprächen auch bei
ihnen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ein
großes verantwortungsbewusstsein
wahrgenommen wir alle wissen dass es um
das leben und die unversehrtheit unserer
soldaten geht
die fraktionen der ampel koalition
unterstützen die verlängerung des
irak-einsatzes damit übernimmt der
deutsche bundestag verantwortung für die
sicherheit und den frieden in der welt
wir haben aber auch durch änderungen des
mandats begründeten bedenken rechnung
getragen nur stabile gesellschaftliche
und staatliche strukturen sichern
langfristig den frieden deshalb ist der
zivile aufbau die entscheidende säule
des irak einsatzes dieser aufbau aber
braucht sicherheit und darum ist der
beitrag der bundeswehr unverzichtbar der
dienst unserer soldatinnen und soldaten
im einsatzgebiet verdient größte
anerkennung
eine neue qualität wird dadurch erreicht
dass die bundesregierung den einsatz im
kommenden jahr umfassend überprüfen wird
eine solche evaluierung hätte auch dem
afghanistan einsatz durchaus gut getan
leider war sie mit der cdu nicht möglich
die ampel koalition geht jetzt neue wege
und wir werden diese evaluierung im
parlament konstruktiv begleiten
zahlreiche aussagen führen der irakische
regierungsvertreter zeigen immer wieder
die zustimmung die unser einsatz dort
genießt darüber hinaus werden wir wert
darauf legen dass die iranische
zivilgesellschaft in die evaluierung mit
einbezogen wird
[Applaus]
weil unsere ressourcen begrenzt sind
aber auch aus moralischen gründen ist
ein auslandseinsätze der bundeswehr
ein strenger maßstab anzulegen ob sie
unsere sicherheit erhöhen und den
frieden in der welt dienen im falle des
irak mandats sind diese voraussetzungen
ohne jeden zweifel erfüllt der fähigkeit
aufbau des irakischen sicherheitssektors
bleibt angesichts der fortgesetzten
anschläge des sogenannten islamischen
staates wichtig wir sichern den zivilen
aufbau ab wir unterstützen streitkräfte
anderer staaten und zeigen solidarität
mit unseren verbündeten das ist gelebte
bündnistreue die bundesregierung und der
deutsche bundestag sind verlässlich und
gemeinsam mit unseren verbündeten
stellen wir uns unseren aufgaben
vor allem aber ist der einsatz der
bundeswehr notwendig weil der
islamistische terrorismus nach wie vor
gefährlich ist die terroristen setzten
die im universalen menschenrechts
verständnis der freiheitlichen
demokratien den absolutheitsanspruch
ihrer steinzeitlichen religions-
auslegung entgegen scharia körperstrafen
und das völlig verängstigte frauenbild
der terroristen stehen im krassen
widerspruch zu jeder vorstellung einer
freiheitlichen und zivilisierten
gesellschaftsordnung während seines
kurzlebigen siegeszuges hat der
sogenannte islamische staat ungeheures
leid über die menschen in der region
gebracht die vertreibung und ermordung
von zahllosen unschuldigen menschen und
die verschleppung und vergewaltigung von
frauen mädchen waren in ihrer brutalität
erschütternd dort hat sich eine
menschheits katastrophe abgespielt und
der islamistische terrorismus ist noch
nicht besiegt seine bekämpfung ist eine
schicksalsfrage für die gesamte
menschheit im dieser schicksalsfrage
lassen wir die irakerinnen und iraker
nicht im stich ich bitte sie um
zustimmung vielen dank meine damen und
herren
ganz herzlichen dank ich schließe
hiermit die aussprache